[Music]
actress mila yvich may never get to
bring the speedy thundercat into live
action but plenty of parents already
have in a way meet chitara if you
haven't met one already
if there's one thing that chitara has
going for her it's her speed after all
she is based on the cheetah the fastest
land animal on earth it comes as no
surprise that lionel sweats bullets when
he learns that one of his trials to
become the official leader of the
thundercats is a race against chitara
however as episode 42 of the original
thundercats demonstrates chitara's
agility is not without its disadvantages
her speed only lasts for a short period
of time after that shiitara runs as fast
as any other thundercat when chitara and
lionel run alongside each other at the
end of the episode lionel is able to
outpace chitara at first lino doesn't
believe he triumphed honestly and
accuses chitara of letting him win this
upsets her as it goes against the code
of thundera only after chitara explains
to lionel that the race drained her
super speed and his determination gave
him an edge does he finally accept the
outcome
everyone knows the look of chitara but
not enough has been said about her voice
lynn lipton in american film stage
television and voice actress didn't just
voice chitara she voiced every female
character who appears in the first
season of thundercats season 1 consists
of 65 episodes so the fact that lipton
voiced literally every non-male
presenting character on the show is an
incredible accomplishment you may
mesmerize men with your evil beauty but
i am a woman you hold no mystery for me
while other talented women have also
voiced chitaras such as emmanuel shriki
in the 2011 reboot and erica lindbeck in
thundercats roar lipton will always be
seen as the definitive voice of the
character lipton even reprised the role
for the family guide direct to video
movie stewie griffin the untold story
which also included larry kenny
reprising his role as lionel
although lino and chitara have their
moments together in the original series
tigra is typically portrayed as
chitara's one and only romantic partner
in the wildstorm comics thundercats the
return tigra heals the emotional wounds
of chittara after they are freed from
their five-year captivity through the
course of healing their trauma tigra and
chitara start an intimate relationship
with each other fifteen years later the
two are officially married and become
the parents of the new thunder kittens
in the 2011 thundercats tv series tigra
and lionel who are depicted as adoptive
brothers have a sibling rivalry with
each other which extends to winning the
affection of chitara in the end tigra is
the one who wins chittara's heart
unbeknownst to tigra and chitara their
confession of love is witnessed by liona
which stirs up complicated feelings of
resentment and jealousy in the future
ruler of thundera unfortunately the 2011
series was cut short before this spicy
drama could be fully explored
there's more to chitara than her super
speed her less mentioned power but
arguably her most important one is her
ability to see events that take place in
the past and future with a game-changing
ability like this why doesn't chitara
use it more in the animated series well
that's because her sixth sense is
presented more as a curse than a
blessing
can't you hear it i don't hear anything
i'm getting some kind of transmission
when the visions occur the timing is out
of chittara's hands and they often cause
her emotional and physical pain
requiring a recovery period that can
take days or weeks in episode 26 of the
series chitara's sixth sense becomes
mentally linked with an alien ship that
crash lands on third earth controlling
her mind and draining her strength
eventually chitara does manage to tap
into her sixth sense without it taking
her completely out of commission
given the number of dormant franchises
from the 80s and 90s being revived for
today's market it seems crazy that the
thundercats has been left untapped for
so many years while it seems unlikely
that a theatrical live-action
thundercats movie will be released
anytime soon one actress might have
expressed interest in playing the series
leading female feline a quote attributed
to resident evil movie star miliabovic
expressing interest in playing chitara
has been republished on numerous
websites she allegedly said i've always
loved thundercats i heard they were
making a movie and then they weren't
making a movie and i'm probably getting
way too old to play catra no chitara
that's the one yovovich supposedly said
this back in 2017 but sadly not much has
changed about the status of the on-again
off-again thundercats movie
parents naming their children in honor
of their favorite fantasy franchises
isn't exactly a new phenomenon after all
there are plenty of kids in today's
world named after harry potter and game
of thrones characters but when it comes
to naming kids after thundercats
characters lino seems more appropriate
for a pet cat than a human
nonetheless that didn't stop several
moms and dads of the 80s from naming
their kids after their favorite
thundercat
i
am chitara
in my heart i know i'm the strongest of
my kind
according to the baby name blog nancy's
baby names seven baby girls were named
chitara after the character debuted in
1985. in 1986 36 baby girls were also
named after chitara with 29 more girls
named in 1987 and an additional nine
baby chitaros in 1988. there's currently
no information for 1989 suggesting
that's where the trend may have ended
however that still leaves 81 people
named after jitara in the united states
now that's wild
despite a promising start the 2011
reboot of thundercats had its life cut
short on cartoon network a variety of
factors worked against the new series
with the most significant disadvantage
being that its toy line wasn't selling
enough for its parent company bandai as
acknowledged by series art director dan
norton it's a shame as the new
thundercats had ambitious plans for its
second season one of which would have
been an episode dedicated entirely to
chitara according to a 2017 interview
norton claimed that the fourth episode
of season two would have focused on
chitara and her status as the last
cleric of thundera the audience would
have also been introduced to an old
rival of chitara described as a snow
leopard the episode would have also
revealed that chitara blames herself for
her grandma's death as she wasn't fast
enough to deliver medicine for her when
she forgave herself the weights that
chitara had been wearing would break
chitara would also gain the ability to
see into the future in this episode just
like in her original incarnation
even the most casual of fans will
remember most of the original characters
from the 1985 thundercats cartoons the
second season however introduced three
new feline characters to the thundercats
crew pamyra linxo and bengali resembling
an alternate color tigra bengali is the
blacksmith of the crew specializing in
forging and repairing weapons most
notably he fixes lino's sword of omens
after it gets snapped in two in the 2011
reboot pumira is introduced in season
one and if the show had lived on bengali
would have appeared as well according to
an interview with dan norton bengali
would have appeared as the son of
chitara and tigra given how similar
tigra and bengali look in the original
series one would assume that making
bengali tigra's son was a way for the
2011 crew to explain their extreme
similarities
[Music]
you